all right great to see so many people
showing up for a security talk I'm
really happy about that
first of all Who am I my name is Alan I
work at a company called Blanc in Oslo I
spend most of my days as a developer but
also do fair a fair bit of security
stuff like security testing some bug
bounty hunting and also and the main
author behind retire Jase and I'm the
head of the a wasp chapter in Norway I
was I was when I first created this talk
I was thinking a bit about the o F top
10 because a lot of people know the OS
top 10 and I was doing a bit of bug
bounty hunting reading quite a lot of
bug bounty reports and I started to see
this thing where a lot of the bugs that
people would find in in bug bounty
program were not a part of the OWASP top
10 so there were a lot of new types of
bugs that were appearing and I thought
it would be interesting to like bring
this out to everyone because there
aren't that many people that are as
interested in me in security that they
trawl for all of these reports all the
time although that's very useful to do
so some of the things I'm going to show
you are kind of a part of the OS top-10
because they've kind of been included
eventually and or parts of them have
been included but I'm also gonna show
you things that aren't and I'm gonna
quickly move outside of the OS top-10
I'm also either really brave or really
stupid so I'm gonna do some demos which
might fail but they usually succeed and
I hope they will today as well if we go
to these bug bounty platforms this is
some statistics from from 2018 from but
proud and one of the things we see here
is cross-site scripting you can see them
in orange and in purple at the bottom
that this is a very prevalent bug and
this matches pretty well with the u.s.
top 10 and we also see server-side
injection in the blue which matches the
OS top 10 a one
if we go to hacker 1 which is another
platform this is their 2019 statistics
we see that they've divided it by by
industry so we see transportation all
the way to the left and we have
healthcare and we have telecom and
travel and hospitality and all kinds of
different industries again we see
cross-site scripting as the most common
problem that we see there but we see a
lot of other things popping up as well
one of the things that I briefly
mentioned that I like to do is to follow
these bug bounty programs and see the
reports that come out of them because a
lot of bugs are they publish the reports
so they someone reports a bug they fix
the bug and then they publish it so and
some of them have a lot of details about
how they attacked went on and and how it
was performed and some of them are
redacted so they they give very little
information but quite a lot of them are
things that we can learn a lot from we
can either follow the disclosed age one
trader account or we can go directly to
hacker one and go to the activity page
we'll see the same thing there as we saw
on the traitor account this is just a
Twitter account that's tweeting the same
thing that you see here if we go to one
of these reports this is one that I
reported to hacker 1 in node.js library
called assemblee Phi which is a sample
validation library where they had what's
called a XML signature bypass so I could
basically be whoever I wanted to be and
bypass the validation that was in that
library and so there's a description
here that describes how I went about
doing that and that I've already
mentioned some will summarize XML and
XML is so much fun
XML can do so many weird things we think
of XML as a markup language but the
parsers of this markup language they are
weird and funny and scary so we have
these this little application this
application here and we have the request
up here this is the request and when I
hit the send button I get the response
down here so if I send there's multiple
times you'll see that the ID down here
is changing so it's increasing I can
send this so I'm actually sending
these requests from my slides and we can
get one of these and I'll get the one
with the idea of one so I'll get the
first one and it looks like this so
there's nothing in the request but
there's something in the response in
this case then we have X X e this was
now a part of the OS top ten that came
out in 2017 but we can do it in xx e is
we can define entities so I've defined
an entity here called content content is
a system entity which will contain the
contents of this file and then I will
use this entity down here so now it
takes the contents of this file puts it
into a variable and then but still has a
part of the XML oh wow I can read files
that's fun but then Java is very
permissive so instead of file I can just
do dot that lists all the files in the
folder I'm in what's useful the slash
gives me the route but back to dot there
was a file there it seemed interesting
this one I want that one Summer 2018
very common password so this is why this
is super dangerous
we can we can basically read any file
there is the limitation it has to be the
end result has to be valid XML or else
the parser will say hey yeah I got
something but I can't parse it because
it's not valid XML one other thing that
we can do is we can use XSLT so we can
use success LTE to transform an XML into
a different form of XML or even HTML so
in this case I can send in an XSLT I can
transform the first contact that I
created into HTML so you can see this is
HTML body table very simple HTML down
here and of course XSLT is they have
functionalities as well so we can start
to query things like system properties
so if I'm at an attacker and I can
control the XSLT I can start to query
the system so in this case I can figure
out what version it is so this is XSLT
version two and that's very useful for
me because I will see in a minute that
it has a functionality that I really
like
as an attacker and you can also see like
the provider and things like that so the
first thing we can do is we can use a
function called document document in
XSLT allows us to take an XML and
include it in the current XML so in this
case I'm gonna read out pom.xml which is
the Java or maven descriptor of this
application and I can see all the
versions of things that are using so
there maybe they're using a vulnerable
library of some kind that I can attack
later but I can read out any file that's
an XML basically I can also do xx e in
the XSLT because the XSLT is also an XML
file so I can do the exact same thing
that I started out with I can include
this it is a password file into the XSLT
result and then I get the same file now
in XSL t 2.0 they included a new
function called on parsed text and this
is great because now it doesn't have to
be valid XML anymore now I can include
any file so it works the same way as
document grabs the contents of a file
and puts it in the XML but I didn't
mention one thing system entities don't
have to be files you could kind of see
it that I had at what file colon slash
blahblah in the first version err we can
we can query the local network so we can
go around figuring out which ports are
open so in this case I'm going to
another server that's only available
from inside the network and it's running
on port 9211 since so I can now reach
this elasticsearch instance through the
XML parser and I can sort of map out the
internal network I could do port
scanning I could do things like that
through this bug so it's super dangerous
sometimes we can't see the result of the
parsing maybe it's parsed later maybe we
will post the file in on some time later
minutes hours or just a seconds later
it's going to be parsed but we can't see
it we can get the parser to send us the
file instead instead of just showing it
in response so what I'm doing in this
case in this example here is I'm
defining a let's say a variable
that can be used in the DTD that's
called data and data will contain the
contents of this file and then I'm going
to grab a DTD from an external source
that I control which is down here and
I'm going to also include the contents
from that file down here and then this
one defines a new entity called external
entity which I'm including down here and
in that entity I'm using the data of our
variable all the way from the top and
then I'm gonna put this entity down here
so what essentially happens is it does
all this parsing and grabbing and stuff
and then it calls the URL down here with
the data extract it up here
so I can get it to send me the file by
an HTTP request instead of having to get
to the actual response back there are
many ways of doing this
there's a really good resource on github
that explains this for various different
parsers so this is an example from
hacker one from Twitter they had an x XE
bug and as we can see Twitter paid ten
thousand and eighty dollars for this bug
even though it was only rated as a
medium bug but that's quite a decent sum
of money to report one single bug but
that's because it's it is really
critical so how do we stop this well we
can disable DTD support it really
depends on the parser we can disable the
DD support we can enable so-called
secure XML parsing and we can disable
external entities so OS has created a
cheat sheet where we can see some of
these things but in dotnet luckily they
have disabled this since version 4.5.2
and you'd have to be in abel it for it
to work but in java there are so many
ways that you have to disable it you
think you disable it and then it doesn't
work so what I suggest write a unit test
that tests your parser and checks that
it's actually disabled and you don't
just think that it's disabled because
I've had this happen multiple times
where I think I've disabled it and it
wasn't disabled after all sorry
use regular expression for
for parsing XML well I wouldn't do that
next thing binding and serialization
this is also something that quickly can
go wrong when we're doing serialization
were taking an object of some kind and
we're sterilizing it down to a format
that we can transfer or store so Jason
is an example of this we have a
server-side object a Java object or a
net object and we transfer it to Jason
so we can send it either to a client or
to a database or whatever and then later
we deserialize it we take it back from
this storage or transfer format and back
into an actual object then we use this
everywhere we use this in our PC we use
this in all kinds of water protocols web
services message brokers caching etc etc
this is something we use everywhere even
in jobs like that's also a form of a
server station at each civilization so
we can imagine it looks something like
this so civilization we have this Jason
Reiter class we give it an object and
say write this object as as a J's and
then when we want it back we specify the
type and we specify the data and we say
I want a type of object back but usually
it is not as simple as this this is the
way we kind of think it would work and
that's fine but let's say we have this
class with this class called person and
person has a name and if we seriously
serialize and deserialize this object
nothing bad happens I mean it has a name
it has a processing the property nothing
bad but then we have this other class
which is not intended to be a part of
the API but if we were able to
instantiate this class if we were able
to run the constructor of this class it
would actually start a process so this
is bad programming right we shouldn't
have like things that happen in the
constructor like this but there are
gadgets like this around so gadget is
something we can use for DC realization
attacks so this is a really simple
example we can imagine then if someone
sent this XML here I'm sorry this Jason
here this XML here where you can specify
the type and this is the thing if I can
specify as an attacker the type that I
want to these
sighs deserialize - then I might be able
to find one of these gadgets so here
it's the dollar type which is common for
Jason and here is type equals which is
common for XML now usually it's not as
simple as having a single class usually
we have to combine gadgets so this is an
example from the presentation framework
for dotnet
so in this case we have to create
something called an object data provider
which again creates a process which
takes some arguments in this case the
calculator and runs the method called
start a very convenient thing right we
can ask this object data provider to
create an object of a specific kind and
then run a method on it so but of course
this would be terrible and this is from
a library on github called why so serial
dotnet where they have a lot of these
gadgets for dotnet and there's also why
so serial which has other gadgets for
other languages but I promised you demos
so our my first demo I'm gonna I use
just create a process and I'm gonna
create a process through something that
spring has that's called a dynamic proxy
so I'm gonna tell spring hey I want a
dynamic proxies of this contact object
are you normally create so this is the
exact same application that I use to
begin with I wanna create a dynamic
proxy which has an event handler which
actually starts the process now I click
the send button I get a 500 error back
right ah bummer but if we look all the
way down here the other long UNIX
process cannot be cast - Yahveh long
string huh so maybe we were onto
something
but I mean pinging something boring
let's hack it so in this case I'm gonna
start a shell and I've got a pipe that
shell back to my hacker box that's it's
air so dev TCP evil dot hackers slash 1
3 3 7 that's gonna contact that it's
gonna send the shell to that host name
on that port so we of course we have to
listen on that port so let's do that
start a listener on that port and we
send the payload and now I have a shell
on that box and I'm route yay so I can
do anything I could do LS I can do
whatever a bunch poked around the server
here's an example from hacker one from
Starbucks where someone found a
dissertation remote code execution bug
in their JBoss mq instance it doesn't
say how much money they got but at least
it says it was critical underlying costs
well we allow the client to specify the
type and we allow the client to
instantiate dangerous gadgets so this is
something you don't want if you want to
allow the client to specify types at
least you have to constrain it to
certain namespaces or packages and maybe
they should have specific annotations or
attributes to be allowed to be a part of
the serialization or you could just
disable specification of types also keep
your frameworks up to date flow Jackson
the Java Jason framework has had a lot
of these bugs to keep them up to date
next one is template injection our
template injection is kind of a part of
most often a one injection it was kind
of snuck in at the last minute and
template injection is about these
templating frameworks that we're using
so we have all of these frameworks that
we're using for creating HTML or XML or
something else but let's let's go with
HTML for now so on the server side this
could be like razor for dotnet or
velocity or Jade or er beef or Ruby or
whatever it could be any one of those on
the client side on the other hand it
could be react or angular review or some
other templating framework that allows
us to generate HTML from some type of
data so a simple template could look
something like this so we have h1 tag
and then we have these curly braces and
a variable so this would take the
contents of the variable and insert them
into there and it often at least in the
first versions it was implemented
something like this so you would take
this you tokenize it into h1 start H one
end and then you would do eval on the
thing in a center like the template
itself in the center there and get the
value and that works perfectly
so if it title was hello and the
template was this h1 thing then the end
result would be h2 on hello perfect
that's exactly what we want the problem
occurs once we start to use components
and we start to have multiple of these
templates and we some times put one
rendered component into another
component like in this case and you see
the dot dot dot this doesn't have to be
so close in vicinity in the code like
this might be different function calls
and it might be so you can't really see
what's going on but just to keep it
simple we have this right next to each
other so we have a first we render one
template with some variable and then we
put the result of that into a new
template and this is where it goes wrong
because it works if we test it like no
hello and world it's gonna work so the
end result of the first one is going to
be h1 hello h1 and then we put that in
the second template and we render dad
and it's gonna be hello world it's going
to look like everything works as
expected the problem happens if the
first variable contains a template in
itself because then that template
actually get renders as a part of
rendering the second template because
we're double evaluating the the first
template so we take this title thing and
we insert it in and we can see the end
result sitting in header now contains a
new template which is then rendered in
the next line and I mean in this case it
was two times two equals four well that
that's not that bad we can do math but
we could do a lot worse so here once
again we have an application in this
case we see that you'll see the rendered
HTML in the top frame and the raw
response in the bottom frame so I send
in my name and you can see it rendered
as hello Allen and you can see down here
h1 hello Alan so if I change this to
let's say we see it says hello I would
have in both places nothing special
about that then I send in a template now
it says hello six we can see the
rendered result says hello six but it
also says six coming back from the
server
so obviously this template that I
specified in the URL was some
executed so we can start to poke around
and try to figure out what is this
this templating framework that's running
here and I do underscore self in this
case and I'm suddenly shown this error
message this is recoverable fatal error
twig template environment dot PHP aha
and it says eval code this doesn't sound
so good so obviously this is PHP it's
using a framework called twig and I'm
able to inject stuff into it what can we
do that well we can register a filter
called accept and then we can specify
the command that this filter will run
which in this case is ID so it just runs
the ID command on Linux which returns
the current user but boring yes we want
to hack the server so we do the exact
same thing that we did for the
disorganization attack we create a shell
pipe it back to our to our beautiful
hacker box down here so we listen on
port 1 3 3 7 we send in the attack and
I'm now on the server as this user and I
can poke around and do whatever I want
and you can see the minute I did ctrl C
to terminate the shell yeah it actually
returned back here we can do that once
more send and it's waiting and waiting
and when I do this you can see it kind
of blinks because then it actually
returns the HTML response it was waiting
for this process to finished eventually
it would rather timeout but yeah
I'm in the server if I want but this was
server-side so we could see the 6 was
coming back from the server when I sent
2 times 3 up here what about the
client-side so in this case it says 6 up
here but here down here it still says 2
times 3 why is that well in this case
it's because we have angular involved so
angular said sir as a library and I have
ng app here so this thing is treated as
an angular template so angular will pick
this up and say hey there's a template
here I'm gonna execute it and then it's
gonna return 6
so the immediate thing we take out we
can do cross at scripting now we can do
alert 1 and see if we can get that and
going then nothing happens that's weird
well that's because angular used to have
a sandbox and this sandbox were supposed
to disallow you to run arbitrary
JavaScript you should only be allowed to
run certain types of JavaScript the kind
of JavaScript where you've got your data
out and things like that
unfortunately this sandbox was broken
multiple times and this is one way to
break this sandbox in that version so
what we do is we take a stream and we
take the constructor of string which is
the string constructor and then we take
the constructor of the screen
constructor recision which is a function
and we take the function constructor and
we create a new function with alert one
and then we invoke that function
alert and it comes two times as well so
this was a way to bypass that sandbox
and this was going back and forth for a
long time there was some some really
great security researchers that was kind
of messing with this and then the
angular guys fixed it then they found a
new bypass the angular fixed end was
going back and forth up to at some point
where angular just said well we're
actually just going to remove the
sandbox because this is this is not the
way angular is supposed to be used
you're not supposed to be as an attacker
be allowed to specify your own templates
but this happens because we sometimes
mix server and client side templating
here's an example for from rockstar
games they had a injection and this will
paid $1,000 to the person who found it
so how do we discover this well we can
try different types of templates in all
of our input fields like the double
curly braces and dollar a curly braces
percentage curly braces etc etc we can
try generic things like two times two or
four minus one do not do two plus two
because if it's a part of a URL
two plus two will be two space two and
that will probably fail so do two times
2 or 4 minus 1 or something like that
instead as you saw with tweak I did
underscore self so that was a known
construct in a language that I could use
to kind of provoke in error
and we can use this as seen for
cross-site scripting or even for remote
code execution in getting a shell on a
box how to stop it
don't double evaluate templates and
don't mix server-side and client-side
templating that's when things go wrong
and keep your frameworks up-to-date that
always is something you should do next
thing insecure cross-origin resource
sharing this is something we've seen a
lot of lately so we have this thing
access control allow origin what does it
even mean well we try to give you some
we won't want to allow other websites
from other servers to access something
coming from our server so we we ask
google translate it can help us so we
want to translate from HTTP to English
and we insert access control allow
origin example.com access control allow
credentials true this is not possible by
the way this justice but then in English
it will say if the user is logged in and
visits example.com please allow that
site to access to users data so we say
anything coming from example are come
running in the users browser can
actually use the current session tokens
etc of the user when it's talking to me
and you can display the data and then we
have this thing access control allow
origin star access control allow
credentials true so if the user is
logged in please allow any site the user
visits to access the users data this is
a bad idea and the browser's know so
they just disallow it this is not an
loud combination you're not allowed to
do this but developers are clever and
they think aha so that's not allowed
that I'm gonna find a way to circumvent
this anyway because I need this in my
test environment and then we forget and
we push it to production so what are the
mistakes we make first one is the echo
so we grab the origin header and we just
put that into access control allow
origin so if it's example to come it
will say example to comb if it's evil
look calm it was evil calm so we've kind
of reintroduced the star only we've
hacked
um not clever thing to do this is some
one of the things that was discovered by
a guy called James kettle who works out
of ports wigger
and we've seen a lot of this in these
bug bounty reports next one insufficient
validation we grab the region header
once again now we're gonna we're gonna
be smart we're gonna check that it ends
with example.com because that's the only
thing we want allow but we won't allow
the subdomains as well the problem is
though that not example.com also ends in
example.com so this is broken the last
one is null
well no what does not even mean access
control allow origin null what's the
null origin
let's ask Google Translate once more
access control original if the user is
logged in please allow any site the user
visits to access the users data as long
as the site knows how to use iframe with
the sandbox attribute looks like this so
we create an iframe we set sandbox allow
scripts allow forms and then rerun the
ajax call inside of this iframe this
gives us an original null and we're
allowed once again to read the data this
is again the star and true here's an
example from tomato comm this is james
kettle who I just mentioned who reported
this and if we see here ending in Samara
com including Natsume TOCOM so this was
the exact bug in number two that I just
shown next thing we're going to look at
is something called server-side request
for jury service ID request forgery is
something that happens if we have a
setup where we have let's say a browser
or some other type of client we have
maybe HTTP we're running or some
requests into a server application and
that server application it runs HTTP
requests towards some other application
it might be a back in service but it
could also be something online somewhere
the problem in this case is if the
browser
could somehow affect how the second
httprequest is formed or where it's
going so an example so we have a request
coming in from the browser that looks
like this example.org / images 200 times
200 product JPEG in our server
application we try to replace the first
bit so we try to take away HTTP example
at org and we add images example at org
then we go out and we do an HTTP request
to get that and return us back to the
user so we strike out the first part
replace it with images and then grab the
contents and then return it to the user
yeah that works alright we're happy we
pushed the production and then this
thing comes long images dot evil calm
okay so we strike at the first part and
we end up with this images dot
example.org dot evil calm okay
that's obviously not what we wanted and
now if this call to the back-end service
also included a username and password
this would now be sent to evil comm
instead of where it was originally
planned to go we can even do more we
could do something like this so in this
case images dot example.org would become
the username and then dummy would become
the password and then what comes after
the @ would be the actual host that we
would go to so it would be treat this as
basic authentication in some frameworks
sometimes we have functionality like
this this could be to read in an RSS
feed to read in some financial data
whatever so like we can specify the URL
that's a part of the functionality and
then we have to make sure that we don't
allow dangerous things like this so in
this case I'm gonna go to the MongoDB
that sits on the same server and just
grab stuff out of there which is
obviously not what the developers of
this application intended or sometimes
these parsers also allow us to specify
file URLs and we can read files as well
which is handy if you are if you have
malicious intentions but where this has
really gone wrong is on cloud because on
the cloud especially on AWS you have
this thing called the metadata host you
have the
another cloud provider as well and it
runs on port one six nine two five four
one six nine two five four and we can
ask it about things we can ask you about
like what is this server I'm running on
and we can even ask it for keys and
credentials for that host so now if I
can from the outside ask it to return
the contents of these metadata calls to
me I can get the keys to the host and
then I can just SSH into the host which
could be useful and this has happened
many many times actually we've seen a
lot of examples of people who have
gotten lots of data stolen this way but
we could also first go to other types of
things like MongoDB or even DB or any
other HTTP enabled service so we're
gonna be smart we're gonna blacklist the
IP because we don't like this IP it's
dangerous I was this IP four to five
five one zero four to five it's it's
it's above 256 well a lot of these
parsers they will just do mod 256 and so
it will become the exact same IP these
two are often equivalent this is from a
guy called Nikola Gregoire who did an
amazing talk called server-side browsing
considered harmful around this topic
what about this thing well that's a
numeric IP this is an America P with
overflow a hexadecimal IP hexadecimal RP
without dots with overflow octal IP
octal lucky with overflow so these are
all the same IP it just looked very
different we can do more we could
register our own domain name to point to
let's say localhost so we have even
Lacombe we register custom come to point
227 zero zero one but someone's done
that for us already they've called
created something called sip IO so far
they 127 0 0 1 dot zip tie out I will
always resolve to localhost we can even
base 36 encoded so it looks a little
less suspicious or even add stuff in
front of it so it says dub dub dub dub
actor I know and then the rest of it
will still resolve to the same IP so
this is getting difficult
and then there's 0 0 0
which is all interfaces on the machine
and doesn't have to be serious or one it
could be 127 four times and ipv6 oh yeah
and then there's a guy who calls himself
orange sigh who did an amazing talk
about breaking URL parsers and he found
this thing like if you parse this on
different machines you'll get different
results on Windows it will see it as a
UNC path but on Linux it will see it as
a file URL so it will turn different
things depending on a machine so you can
get create like polyglot URLs to steal
files amazing stuff and then you have
things like this like Apache Tomcat
things that dot dot semicolon is the
same as dot dot slash and yeah that
breaks things as well here's an example
this is from hacker Iran and they found
bug in alienvault and we can see the IP
down here is 122 6925 460 925 for
metadata nicob net which is Nicola
Gregoire I just mentioned so how do we
detect that this is going on well we can
build a [ __ ] log so we can say that
any HTTP client that we have in our code
it's going to log all the calls that it
makes and all the return codes and
things like that and this is good anyway
because we want to know what's clogging
down our system are we doing a lot of
phage DB requests we could have timing
we've had all kinds of metrics to this
everyone but at least we'll know if it's
trying to access things it shouldn't we
could have an outgoing proxy to ensure
that we can reach other internal
services we can normalize the hostname
resolver to an IP before actually
requesting it so we can ask what's the
actual IP that you're going to ask
before we do the request and we could
have local firewall routes and since
this application is not allowed to
access one six nine to five for its era
because we won't allow that
next subdomain takeover subdomain
takeover was something that at least
partially was discovered by France
person of Detective I I think there were
some other people looking at the same
thing at the same time but he's credited
for finding it and he wrote a great blog
post about this back in 2014 but it's
still a bit of an unknown thing for most
people so what this does it
sports what we call forgotten DNS
aliases cname aliases so we have all
these cloud services and we let's take
care of you as an example they've
actually done a bit to stop this thing
but let's go with her aqua for now so we
have we can create an application on
Heroku we will get our subdomain as a
part of the URL so it as a part of the
host name so it could be like Ladera
crapcom
but we wanted to be a relative calm not
hero crapcom so we won't have a custom
domain name same thing goes for other
types of services like s3 buckets and
things like that we get these names and
we kind of put things there and use them
and there are a lot of services that
allow this like github Heroku AWS
bitbucket Squarespace etc and detective
I found over 100 different services that
allow this so we create an application
Owensboro crapcom but we want this to
actually run on our domain called
example to come as a subdomain so we go
into Heroku and we configure that this
application is actually going to have a
domain name of OS dot example.com
and then we go to our own dana's and we
say if if you ever see OS example calm
that's actually an alias or a cname for
OS dot example.com dot here aqua dns
TOCOM so instead of resolving it itself
it's gonna just gonna say go to Heroku
DNS and ask them instead so we can
imagine look like this the the browser
goes to look up OS lot assembler Combe
talks to our DNS which says hey you
should actually go see this hero cadenas
thing instead so we go over there we ask
what's the IP for this thing we get an
IP back and then we reach the service we
want and this works as intended so yeah
we're happy we get results everything
works perfectly and we have this
application sitting there for some time
but then something bad happens
we're tired of this application we don't
need it anymore we it was for an event
than that event is over and we just go
into Heroku and we delete it done but we
forget to remove the DNS entry so we're
now we still have a DNS entry or was
that example accom pointing to
Medina's so what the attacker can do is
go in and create an application with the
same name and now the attacker controls
our subdomain so what can you do if you
control someone's subdomain well you can
go fishing with a proper domain that's
much more likely to succeed if it
actually is OS but org instead of Heroku
app comm we can inject or steal domain
wide cookies so we can inject your own
session cookies to fixate sessions we
can use this for political stuff or for
adults or for whatever we could even
create HTTPS certificates because we now
own this subdomain so here's an example
of a subdomain takeover on s3 for
Shopify and here's another one from
Microsoft where they had this domain
they used two four four tiles and they
host the to delivery XML files
notification dot build my pinned site
com only showed an error message and a
person figure that he could actually
register this and he would get all the
traffic and here's another example it's
a bit small texture but it says Simon
Gursky has hacked dot prod to do bird
comm so this is from the certificate
transparency log and it stays there
forever because this is the log that
publishes all certificates that have
been published by CAS
so this Simon Girty he was able to hack
into prodigy at ubirr comm through a
forgotten cname and then he issued the
certificate and it stays there in this
log forever last is something called web
cache poisoning and web cache poisoning
was also discovered by James kettle who
I mentioned a few times now James
Carroll works for ports wigger which
creates a tool called Bert's width which
is one of the most common security tools
that the penetration testers are using
and what James was trying to do what he
was trying to exploit what we call
unexploited bugs this could typically be
bugs where you could only affect
yourself like a cross-site scripting
where you could only inject things in
your own browser and cross the scripting
you want to send an attack
where you can attack someone else but
sometimes you have self XSS you can only
attack yourself and he wanted to figure
out a way where he could exploit these
bugs even though it was sort of a self
XSS so he did a lot of research in this
and wrote it a blog post and did a
couple of talks around this so we can
imagine it looks like this so we have
our server and we've set up this cache
in front of it this could be like an
engine X or some other type of reverse
proxy with caching abilities and we have
a client that comes in now the client
goes in and says hey I want this site
and the cache says well I don't have it
so I'm gonna ask the server and we ask
the server we get the data back we store
it in the cache and return it to the
client so when the next client comes
along and ask for the exact same thing
we can say we have this in the cache
this is exactly how a cache works
perfect so now we can save our server
from processing the same things over and
over again if we have a lot of clients
but then our malicious attacker comes
along and the attacker has figured out
that there is a bug in the server so it
sends a payload and the payload misses
the cache and goes straight to the
server and then the result of this
attack where there might be a cross-site
scripting or something like that is
stored in the cache so we've poisoned
the cache so now when a benign client
comes along afterwards and asks for the
same thing they were gonna get the
poisoned version and the attacker can
run cross-site scripting in the client
that got the poisoned person so nothing
without a demo right so here is an
application I can send this in and I get
back this response down here then the
important thing here is this thing it
says dub dub dub dot hackable metric /
script j s okay so it loads the script
tag from from this server now what the
attacker has figured out is if the
attacker sets this specific header
called X forward at hosts and sets it to
something that they want the script tag
will change so now it says attacker calm
here but in this case we poison this URL
or maybe this URL so it says T equals 1
so if we go back to the benign client it
still says dub dub that a cable network
down here so we're gonna remove this and
we're gonna send it once more but now it
still says dub dub dub dub hackable
Network why because we're hitting the
cache we haven't been able to poison it
yet and luckily it tells us that well
the cache is valid for 30 seconds as a
part of the cache control header so we
can just keep going and at some point we
should actually be able to poison the
root page without the parameter there we
go that's attacker calm but we're
sending this header what about the
benign client over here it also gets a
target calm now because we poisoned the
cache so now we'll see how brave you
guys are bring out your phone or your
laptop and go to this page and tell me
what you see I'm not gonna do anything
really bad so no worries what do you see
it's dub dub dub hackable dot Network
the logo of aridif should be there so it
should look like this welcome and then
the logo of our dev so what I'm gonna do
now is I'm gonna poison the cache and
all I'm doing now is I'm sending
requests from my slides to the server
which sits out on the internet and I'm
trying to send this header this extra
header to try to poison it and so this
is gonna take the amount of seconds that
the cache is valid and hopefully I will
be able to poison it once that cache
times out and then I should see a
success message down here
this is the most dangerous of the demos
because it might actually fail I'm gonna
reload and try again
it worked earlier today and that happens
most of them my demos I ran them off a
doctor on my local machine so I'm not
too prone to bad things happening but in
this case it actually seems that it have
decided not to work so we'll leave it
there try to hack and then we can come
back and see if it works in a short
while so these are the headers that
James kettle found X host X forwarded
host X original URL X rewrite URL these
were some of the headers that he
discovered that different frameworks and
servers they were treating them as
special things where they would actually
rewrite things that happen to end up in
the cache so things will end up in
different places that you expected to so
you could send in host and I would grab
that host and use that you could set X
for word host it would do the same thing
you can set X original URL or X rewrite
your own these are things that we
normally use from yeah okay so it worked
hahaha so if you now go back and refresh
the page it seemed that it actually
worked even though it did wasn't able to
detect it so it should look like didn't
work for some of you yeah it worked for
some yeah you get dr. evil on your
phones awesome so it's just my my
browser that's messed up at the moment
great so it actually works so you get
what happens for those who who who
didn't take part is that you get the
images replaced because it's using X for
reddit host to actually replace the host
that's loading the image just loading it
from somewhere else and then you get dr.
evil instead of the logo oh it's a
success now so now it should actually
Frank yeah so we have these headers
these are the ones that James found and
as I was trying to say these are things
that a proxy would send to the back end
so the back end would know what the
proxy originally saw because the the
back end might have a different URL than
the front end and the back end might
want to know what the front end saw or
what your else to put in in in there you
generated URLs in India HTML for
instance this can be a bit complicated
of an attack to perform because we have
to know which URL parameters are used in
the cache keys as you saw I have this T
equals one thing and it's it turned out
the T was a part of the cache key so I
could poison one cache and then I could
then go back and try to poison the root
it could also be headers that are in the
cache keys so for instance we could have
different caches for Firefox and
different for Chrome depending if you
want to serve different contents for
different browsers but James kettle
works for burps right so he created a
plugin for it called para minor and I
think this is only in the paid version
of the tool but this is one of the tools
that you can use to find these things or
you can just go and review your your
cache comfy how do we how do we stop
this well we could block these headers
inbound right there's no point in
allowing a client to set the ex forward
at hosts next host head and all of those
headers those are meant to be used from
the proxy and towards the back end so
they shouldn't be coming in from the
front end another way which James
suggested was we could add those headers
to the cache key so if you have X for a
toast
you will actually get extra read hosts
as a part of the cache key and then and
the nine client wouldn't send that
header and wouldn't get the poisoned
version from the cache but of course in
this case we should also fix the back
end server which in this case just took
a random URL and allowed that to be
included as a part of the HTML so fix
your servers as well we can use burp
switch to also audit this so burps width
as I mentioned is a really good tool
it's a paid to I'm not getting anything
to mention it it's and I have no
affiliation with birth weight I just
like the - so these are some resources
if you want to take a picture these are
some resources that I mentioned so we
have the disclosed h1 Twitter account
all the way to the top we have activity
on hacker one as number two there we
have Y so serial and why so serious
which are these D civilization attack as
examples we have abusing XSLT for
practical attacks and we have template
injection which was also James kettle
we have subdomain takeover from France
or Xen we have this server-side browsing
thing from from Nicaragua there's the
video of James kettles talk on course
misconfigurations from our app sec on
youtube there and also James Cal's blog
post
called practical web cache poisoning so
just gonna go back and see or see if it
actually works now yes it worked so
that's what you're supposed to see and
that's actually it on the bottom of the
screen there is a github URL if you want
to play with the application that I've
showed you not the for the cache
poisoning but for these realizations
attacks and for XML attacks you can
download that app and run it in a docker
container and play with it on there in
the readme file you should specify the
types of requests that you need to send
in to test this and so and if you want
to add new stuff to it and help me build
something that's completely broken then
go ahead but never ever use that for
anything other than fun don't ever use
that as a working system and put it
online just put it run it on doctor
locally don't put it on the Internet
that's it
thank you
[Applause]